so we are moving along lecture six is
the last of the biochemistry lectures
we're going to be talking about
nucleotides and nucleic acids and you'll
understand these terms in a moment there
I'll clarify them for you
but this is a tremendous stepping stone
to the next portion of the class so I'll
show you a few images here I'm going to
reshow you some of these in a moment
when we talk about addressing
understanding the non-covalent structure
of DNA which is so critical to
understanding information storage and
information transfer but for now let's
just have a quick peek forward after
this section I'm going to be covering
molecular biology so how to go from DNA
to RNA to protein and then Professor
Martin will take over with the basic of
structures and functions of cells and
then genetics and but for all of this
we're going to need nucleic acids and
I'll explain to you why here
so nucleic acids form fundamental units
for information storage storage and that
is the DNA that is in our nucleus and in
our mitochondria and then information
transfer and if I get a little bit of
time at the end I have three or four
quick slides that you don't have on your
handout because it's sort of a floating
topic on the use of DNA in DNA based
computing because it's a nanosec scale
structure that one can program to do
different things and I think you might
enjoy that so in this picture of the
components and the what's known as the
central dogma that is how DNA is
converted into messenger RNA which
through the help of transfer RNA and
ribosomal RNA we get proteins the key
elements on this slide are DNA messenger
RNA ribosomal RNA
for RNA and those are all made up of
nucleotides being brought together into
polymers that are nucleic acids so
obviously we really need to crack the
structures of these and understand how
the structure informs function remember
we did that for proteins we've done that
for phospholipids we thought about it
very briefly for carbohydrates but the
thing that I really want to stress to
you with the forth of these
macromolecules is looking at how the
last component of the biomolecules
structure really informs function and
it's really cool to think about how it's
done so how is that chemical molecular
structure something that we can
understand from from the perspective of
function ok so what we need to do first
of all is think about what nucleotides
are and understand their structure so
that we can move forward to understand
how they come together to build these
macromolecules are so pivotal and
essential in life for programming the
biosynthesis of our proteins and now
we're understanding more and more about
not only that but also how RNA RNA not
DNA is involved in a large number of
regulatory processes so it's not just
DNA double stranded DNA goes to a
messenger and so on there's also a lot
of regulation occurs because of a lot of
the other nucleic acids that are within
the cell so I'm going to go here because
I want to describe the composite
components of nucleotides so we
understand their their structure and
their properties so what are nucleotides
and you look at these structures up on
the board they look kind of complicated
so let me deconstruct them for you it'll
make life a lot easier so they're too
familiar building blocks
and one new one so the familiar building
blocks are first of all carbohydrates so
the key carbohydrate in nucleic acid is
a five carbon pentose sugar which looks
like this you can count the carbons four
and five and you can reassure yourselves
everything is there with respect to the
carbons by translating this line angle
drawing into a drawing where you put all
the hydrogen's on and you know where
everything is there are two types of
five carbon pentoses that are used in
the nucleic acid
they are ribose which is shown here with
all oh s on all of those carbons and two
deoxy ribose which is a building block
of DNA whereas ribose is a building
block of RNA what else do I need to tell
you you'll see this later on that ribose
sugar ends up being connected to these
what are known as nucleo bases you don't
do not necessarily need to draw those
because you've got them on your handouts
to put sketches on so I put them on the
board for my so I don't have to stand
here and draw them for you and I want to
explain certain things so the nuclear
bases in the numbering system and I'm
gonna keep on reiterating this so you'll
get familiar with it number the carbons
1 through
whatever it is so rather than numbers
when you're walking around the ring so
when we talk about the ribose component
they have what's known as a prime number
to differentiate it from the numbering
system in the ribose asst so this would
be one prime two prime three prime four
prime at five right why is that this
becomes incredibly important when we
talk about putting together polymers of
DNA and the direction in which DNA is
assembled in life and also even when we
describe to deoxyribose or ribose
because this would be called two prime
deoxyribose in the nucleic acid so I'm
gonna bore you with that numbering
system because I'll start to use it very
commonly and it will make a lot of sense
as we start to assemble the DNA macro
molecule when we talk about the way it's
built and drawn and written the
numbering system will important because
we'll constantly refer to five-prime and
three-prime that's just a little preview
for later the next component of the
nucleic acid is a phosphate thus first
looks like this but in nucleic in
nucleotides these are joined to other
units as phosphor esters but you want to
remember that in phosphorus you have 1 2
3 4 5 bonds to phosphorous and you
commonly have a negative charge on one
of those oxygens and in the structure of
DNA
you actually have foster phosphates
occurring as phosphodiesters
and you once again you will see that
when we see the intact structure of DNA
so what a nucleotides nucleotides are a
combination of a carbohydrate of
carbohydrate or a sugar a phosphate and
a nuclear base that's the third
component the one we're going to learn
about now so the the nuclear bases look
like this there are two families two
flavors of nuclear base there is one
flavor just cleaned up a little bit here
that has two rings and it has the
shorter name purine and there's a
different family or flavor of nuclear
bases that has one ring and it has the
bigger name and that to this day is the
way I remember purines and pyrimidines
small name big structure big name small
structure okay if that's helpful to you
go for it use it I haven't patented it
or anything all right okay so in nucleic
acids there are two different purines
they are known as adenine and guanine
you do not need to know these structures
I actually only know my favorite three
of the five to draw easily and the other
two I'm always stumbling around the ring
so don't worry about that we all get to
know the ones we work with every day for
me it's uracil its adenine and it's
cytosine but not the others okay but
what you do need to understand is a
little bit about their structures
because when we start to talk about the
non-covalent structure of nucleic acids
for instantly the double stranded helix
of DNA we need to know where the
hydrogen bond donors and acceptors are
in these structures so if you want to
indulge me you can take a look at these
structures this hydrogen would be a
donor right you can see that it's a
hydrogen on a nitrogen this nitrogen is
interesting it has one two three bonds
to nitrogen which means there are a lone
pair of electrons also on that ring
systems
so that would be a hydrogen bond
acceptor and the adenine nuclear base
can accept and give a pair of hydrogen
bonds and you can work that out for all
of the others
so in guanine there is an acceptor
another acceptor the donor and so on so
those rings in the nuclear bases are
very important because they have places
that you can hydrogen bond to now is
everyone feeling comfortable about this
does anyone want to ask me a question
that might help clarify because it's
quite a bit yeah do you have a question
sorry uracil these are all up these all
I'm sorry these all these nuclear bases
have fancy names okay so so far I've
shown you the structure of adenine
guanine cytosine and thymine uracil
which is not drawn on the board is very
similar to Phi mean except this methyl
group is a hydrogen okay knowing the
names is also complicated I really care
that you understand hydrogen bonding
patterns not to draw the whole
structures but to identify hydrogen
bonding patterns not to remember fancy
names because there's no logic to those
names but really to remember ribose
deoxyribose phosphate and
phosphodiesters purines and pyrimidines
just the sizes of them to pick them out
does that make sense what I want you to
know and what you can remember if you
think it's interesting okay all right
now in nature we use nucleic we use the
nucleotide building blocks or the
nucleotides in many different ways it's
not just in DNA and RNA and so here I'm
showing you some really important
nucleotides that are found in nature
and I'll give you a little bit of
information about their signaling so
here are the building the components
that you can pick out there is a in this
case a ribose sugar in this case it's
phosphate but it's a phosphite triester
so it's got three phosphates in a row
and here's a nuclear base which is a
purine and this is adenosine
triphosphate so it's one of the bases
that one of the nucleotides that used in
energy energy transfer in a lot of
metabolic processes we use ATP as a
molecule that can you that has energy
that can be unlocked for chemical
processes there's another one of these
which is guanosine triphosphate whether
the nuclear base is different they're
both purines but they have different
structures you can see them there and
then finally the last one I show you
here is an is a nucleotide that has a
cyclic phosphate but it still has a
nuclear base a ribose and a phosphate
and this is cyclic ANP and when we when
I come back after professor Martinez
taught we'll talk about the role of
cycling campi as a second messenger so
these two molecules in addition to being
building blocks for DNA and RNA also a
forms of energy where you can use ATP or
GTP as a form of energy in a lot of
metabolic processes and in fact though
when we start constructing proteins
using the ribosomal system you'll notice
we use gtp as a form of energy not ATP
it's interesting how nature chooses to
do that any questions about this okay
all right one tiny wrinkle left to deal
with and that's a little bit more about
those building blocks for the nucleic
acid one more item that it's useful to
understand the name of so here are the
five nuclear bases two purines and three
pyrimidine x' in DNA we have a tea
nc so a T G and C so we have different
building blocks one three of the three
are common to both polymers one is
different
uracil and thymine are exchanged when
you go from DNA to RNA the pyrimidines a
cytosine uracil and thymine and in RNA
you have a u G and C so there are
reasons for these differences and I'll
get a nudge into some of those chemical
differences in a moment so that what the
information up there is the same
information that I have on this board
the next thing I need to talk to you is
we very commonly use the term two terms
nucleoside and a nucleotide how
irritating is that the nucleoside is
just the ribose plus the nuclear base
but no phosphates okay as soon as you
put on phosphates they become
nucleotides so for example
nucleobase ribose and in this case a
phosphate on it and that becomes a
nucleotide no matter how many phosphates
they are it's called a nucleotide I'm
less concerned that you remember that
nomenclature more that you know what
it's all about because otherwise it
might become a little bit confusing so
just remember if you can remember that
but I've I think I've tried to define
the things I would like you to remember
the building blocks their numbering
system the phosphodiester linkages and
the nuclear bases as far as
understanding where donors and acceptors
are for hydrogen bonding all right okay
and there's one thing so we call that a
nucleoside whereas we call it a
nucleotide when it includes the
phosphates and there's one thing that
you want to notice is that the bond from
the nuclear base to the ribose is a
glycoside bond it's a bond to a
carbohydrate so that's why it's called a
glycoside bond there are glycoside Aizaz
that cleave the bond from the base to
the sugar those are very important when
we have mutations in our DNA and we want
to cut out the sugar to fix it so it
doesn't get misread in the biosynthesis
of DNA in the biosynthesis of messenger
RNA so that bond is important we may
often talk about it
but only when we get to learning about
how DNA sequences are corrected if there
are mistakes in those sequences and that
will be later on okay so let's start to
now look at the polymers now I want to
tell you that by the early 1900's people
pretty much knew the structure the
non-covalent structure of DNA and I'll
describe it to you now DNA is made up of
nucleotides and this is its basic
structure where you have a
phosphodiester backbone linking ribose
each of those ribose iziz modified with
a purine or pyrimidine and that is the
basic structure of a nucleic acid
polymer only it's very very very very
long so let's take a look at the
components here look at the bonds and
you know maybe on your notes just
highlight the bonds and some of the
things I'll talk about so first of all
the numbering system here we always talk
about nucleic acid and we describe the
sequence of the nucleic acid based on
from 5 prime to 3 prime because the
phosphodiester bonds join the 5 prime
there should be a number there and the 3
prime site so the linkage would be here
would be 5 Prime and three prime joining
to the to the ribose molecules so the
architecture of that nucleic acid is a
polymer that includes a phosphodiester
backbone linked by phosphate esters
that's one phosphate ester that's the
other one on two of the OHS of the
ribose sugar when this is DNA there's no
o H group at that carbon site that would
be the two prime site you can see you
can pick straight out that this is DNA
the sequence is then defined by what the
identity of the bases here so this would
be guanine adenine thymine on that
sequence now by convention if we write
out this sequence
the way the sequences are written a 5
prime to 3 prime direction so if I look
at that I would be able to name it as an
a an a G T sequence because we always
write the sequences 5 prime to 3 prime
we can remember that later on because we
actually also build sequences 5 prime to
3 prime so there are some conventions in
biology in biochemistry you want to
remember the by convention we write
peptides in terminal 2 C terminal but we
also build them and to C so that's why
the convention is strong and it's good
to remember because it can get you out
of a lot of trouble if you remember
those things now when we are building a
DNA polymer we grow that sequence you'll
see the biochemistry for all of that
polymerization in the next class it's
amazingly cool how the entire contents
of a cell the DNA can be replicated in
amazing time frames but all through
growing those chains from 5 prime to 3
prime so when we add another building
block on we remove a molecule of water
so that's a condensation reaction and we
form a new phosphodiester bond so in the
biosynthesis of DNA you keep on adding
new nucleotides to the 3 prime end
there's a chemical reason for that when
we build DNA we don't just cram the two
groups together we rather come in with a
triphosphate and use that act
Aveda triphosphate as the new building
block and you kick out triphosphate and
you'll see that when we talk about DNA
synthesis but what I want you to
remember here is this is another
condensation reaction we talked about
them when making peptides we talked
about them when making carbohydrate
polymers and now we're seeing once again
a condensation reaction to make a
nucleic acid polymer now the last term
that's kind of worth mentioning it is
the word nucleic acid what's that about
I don't see any carboxylic acids it
turns out the polymers of DNA are very
acidic because the O H group on those
phosphodiester backbone x' is very
acidic so you give up H+ and this is in
its most stable form as O - so when DNA
was first isolated it was isolated from
white blood cells by isolating the
nucleus and it was found that it was a
very acidic material packed into the
nucleus that's why it was called nucleic
acid acids in the nucleus before people
even understood anything about the
composition it got it garnered that name
nucleic acid so we talked about polymers
of nucleotides we call them nucleic
acids okay all right so then with
respect to writing our sequences we
could write them in this way so PD GATC
that would be that structure what do all
the little extra P's Indies stand for
the P stands for whether there's a
phosphate at this end the d stands for
whether it's a deoxy sugar as a building
block going all the way to the other end
there's no little P at the other end so
it means that which is free does
everyone understand that shorthand
writing there's another way I
no this was DNA without needing to put
deoxy on each of the the building blocks
does anyone know how I know immediately
it's a billet it's a stretch of DNA yeah
yeah there's no uracil on this I mean
instead so in the principle as long as
there's a chi in there you know it's DNA
as long as are you in there you know
it's RNA okay all right now let's talk
about the non covalent structure because
you know I really feel that that's the
most exciting part of this entire
endeavor because the covalent structure
really doesn't allow us to understand
how DNA stores information for building
proteins it doesn't tell us that much
about it it just it looks like a cool
polymer but we can't really understand
the details by not looking at the
covalence of the non covalent structure
so there was one key piece of
information and it's called shoggoths
data and this piece of scientific
information
ran around the scientific community in
the early 50s because it seemed
incredibly important and what Jacques
data was he collected all kinds of
organisms and then their nuclei and then
measured or their DNA and then measured
the ratio between the purines and the
pyrimidines okay he measured the ratio
of the large ones and the small ones of
the nuclear bases so how many of these
relative to how many of those okay
emori found by looking all across
organisms from all domains of life is
that there was a one-to-one ratio of
purine to pyrimidine
so that became very interesting because
what it suggests 'add was that in some
way the non-covalent structure of
nucleic acids had some correlation
between the number of the purines and
the number of the pyrimidines and what
you can imagine is it sounds like we're
always pairing a small one with a large
one by looking at that number so this is
really really important because it's
like the light bulb that went on with
respect to understanding the structure
of double-stranded DNA so despite all
kinds of variations some organisms have
a lot more GCS some have more ATS but no
matter what's the ratio is always
one-to-one and this ultimately led to
understanding the non covalent structure
of double-stranded DNA because it
provided clues to how there could be
some way that information was coded but
then could be replicated now the next
thing that became the clue to the
structure of double-stranded DNA came
from a very talented researcher rosalind
Franklin who sadly died way before her
time of ovarian cancer really in large
part because she spent a lot of time
near x-ray beams so that would have got
caused mutations to her DNA and she
developed a way to make fibrils of DNA
that were ordered in us to collect
electron diffraction data and that
diffraction data actually gave a clue to
some of the dimensions of the
double-stranded DNA structure and it
actually was the clue that told the
spacing between the strands of DNA so it
really was a piece of information that
you simply couldn't do without with char
CAF's data and with this what was called
photograph 51 it really gave you the
clue and it was really during those
years the Watson and Crick were
desperately model building to try to
understand the non-covalent
DNA and once they had those two pieces
of information they could actually put
together hand-built models this looks
kind of clunky but I know the room they
took this photo in from my years at
Caltech in fact I can recognize the room
they built not just little tiny
molecular models but big molecular
models because so they could make
measurements to say the diffraction data
told me this was so many nanometers
apart and they were able to piece
together the structure of
double-stranded DNA but I still haven't
shown you how those two strands to get
come together it's really intriguing
because at that very same time Linus
Pauling have been done very well with
the structure of the Alpha helix and
proteins also was trying to figure out
the structure of DNA but he came up with
a sort of a crazy structure where he
thought that it was a triple stranded
structure where the base is actually
stuck out and somehow this triple
stranded structure coded for replication
of DNA now there's a ton of things that
are really also about this structure
first of all it's a triple stranded but
the other terrible thing is there's so
many phosphodiesterase in the backbone
they would have been massive
electrostatic repulsion those sequences
would want to blow themselves apart
because you can't cram that much
negative all in one place
but it was really intriguing sort of
sociological phenomena at the time
Pauling was a major pacifist and he was
really really active in nuclear
disarmament and they said that his mind
just wasn't on some of this stuff and
that this model came out of him really
worrying about other things and not
focusing on the DNA structure so let's
try to explain
mushara gas data by looking the nuclear
bases and thinking about how they might
come together so here I show you the
structures of the four nuclear bases in
DNA wherever I have an
you can assume that's part that's a
ribose that is part of the
phosphodiester backbone what we want to
understand is how did the nuclear bases
come together to form some kind of tear
that could be could be useful to
programming there resynthesis so I've
drawn them all here but it's not quite
intuitive I need to do a little bit of
flipping around to line things up better
and the other thing I need to do is get
things at the right angle so you can
start seeing how those bases might come
together because char gas data dictates
that you have a purine and a pyrimidine
purine pyrimidine you have pairing
between the nuclear bases in your
double-stranded DNA in a structure that
looks more like this and in each case
you paired a purine and pyrimidine so
what do I want you to do is take a look
I've shown you now where donors and
acceptors are you can go back and do
this for all the nuclear bases but I'm
going to do this for you right now by
showing you the donors and acceptors of
hydrogen bonds within those structures
what I've done is I've lined them up
beautifully so they look straight at
each other so you can tell that there is
a complementarity between a purine and a
pyrimidine that makes very nice hydrogen
bonding which is the non covalent force
that's very important between G and C I
can set up three hydrogen bonds between
a and T I can only set up two hydrogen
bonds so they're one purine is
complimentary to one of the pyrimidines
one purine is complementary to one of
the other pyrimidines all right and then
we can draw those hydrogen bonds in
place that totally explains the
measurement from the Franklin data of
the distance the width of the double
stranded helix because it's identical
for both of those base pair
and that gives you the structure that
forms the non-covalent structure of DNA
which is a series of interactions where
the solid line is the phosphodiester
backbone but sticking out like steps on
a spiral staircase are the bases where
each base is complementary to a specific
additional base all right so it predicts
the SHA gap ratio and it also predicts
the distances now within all the model
building it became quite clear that the
structure the non covalent structure of
DNA was afforded by anti parallel
strands where one strand went in one
direction 5 prime to 3 prime and the
other strand went in the opposite
direction 5 prime to 3 prime when we
start replicating DNA we're gonna see
that that's pretty convenient but
thermodynamically it is also the favored
orientation so let's just look at the
orientation where you would draw one
strand of DNA 5 prime to 3 prime now
I've taken this all down to cartoon
level these are the phosphate digesters
the ribose is the 3 prime end and the 5
prime end and the bases that come off at
the 1 prime carbon and then when you
pair it with another strand one strand
goes in one direction five prime oh I
don't know why this is misbehaving five
prime whoops 5 prime to 3 prime the
other strand goes in the other direction
5 prime to 3 Prime and when asked this
question a few years ago I couldn't
really explain it very well that I just
said it had to be because it always has
been but what's really cool is if people
have been able to solve the crystal
structure of a pair of a parallel pair
of DNA strands so this is canonical DNA
the beautiful anti parallel structure
and it's very regular very very even it
turns out though when you try to pair
the two strands in a parallel
orientation the
very uncomfortable and it's much less
stable so the anti-parallel orientation
is very important for the thermodynamic
stability and the optimum hydrogen
bonding interaction of all those bases
that are pairing so it's actually what
nature favors because it is more stable
any questions okay and this it's on your
slides but you can see just how regular
DNA looks so organized whereas the
anti-parallel one the one the parallel
one really does not afford you good
hydrogen bonding interactions at all
okay so let us know so what we've done
now is we understand the structure of
DNA the coat non covalent and covalent
structure of DNA we understand its
antiparallel what we'll do in the next
class is show how you can peel apart
those anti parallel structures to make
unpaired structures and you can use each
of them as the template for the
synthesis of a new strand of DNA so you
can get two daughter double strands from
a single parent double strand and that
all comes from understanding the
structure now what I want to do is move
you just very briefly to the structure
of RNA and comparing the DNA and RNA
structures because there are some
differences so let's just work through
what the differences are I've have this
written down and the differences are
very important for the functional
properties so DNA RNA first of all
obviously deoxy ribose writers you may
go why why why is nature so complicated
why do I have this extra fact ID to
remember about RNA versus DNA and it's
really amazing that the difference
between that hydroxyl on the two
prime position this is not happening not
having it makes enormous differences to
the stability of the polymer rnase
breakdown very very readily DNA is a
stable for the lifetime of a cell all
perfect in the nucleus or mitochondria
they stay intact so there's a stability
difference between the two sugars
because DNA has to be the place where
you store your genetic material it's got
to stay good whereas RNA is the message
that you make transiently to program a
protein being made and then you want to
get rid of it so we need the differences
in stability that originated from that
small feature a TG C there's the
difference C in the basis the most
common DNA is double-stranded DNA
whereas RNA forms various structures so
it's much more irregular structures than
the DNA probably in part because the
ribose is substituted differently so
that continuous strand of dead of
double-stranded material is not quite so
stable in RNA we find DNA principally as
double stranded DNA but RNA we find as
transfer RNA messenger RNA ribosomal RNA
does go on forever short interfering RNA
so the various RNA is used for a lot of
purposes whereas DNA principally stays
as the double stranded DNA there's a
little double stranded RNA but it is a
precursor to some of these other forms
of RNA okay so this slide just
summarizes some of that for you the
difference is comparing DNA
RNA and so what we'll see later is how
RNA lends itself to these interesting
structures where you still have some
base pairing but you have a lot of loops
and pans and diversity of structure and
that's really kind of the origin of this
RNA world where RNA structures were not
what could have a variety of form that
might contribute to different functions
beyond just as a message as a place to
store DNA message so there are a lot of
things that one can understand about DNA
by knowing its hydrogen bonding patterns
so can you guys guess which of these
strands would have a complimentary stand
and be the most stable double-stranded
DNA so this would be one strand you
could draw for each of them its
complementary strand can you guess the
clues to figuring out which would have a
most stable organization of the anti
parallel double-stranded DNA what would
I be looking for yeah okay so number one
higher GC content because Jesuses form
three hydrogen bonds isn't is only
formed two and what's the other
determinant just looking at those
structures yeah yeah you you are doing
no it's it's actually even more silly
it's more simple than that length so all
you do is you go along and say I can
make three hydrogen bonds 2 3 2 2 3 2 2
2 so usually it's truly just count
hydrogen bonds in its part in the
sequence and you can guess which is
going to be the more stable because it
has the most hydrogen bonds okay so we
might ask you that which one will come
apart now the intriguing thing about DNA
is you can peel it you can heat it and
it'll come apart but it doesn't denature
the way proteins do if you just cool it
down it comes back together so another
feature of DNA is that you can heat
denature and then really Oh
exactly how it was in the first place
it doesn't denature to something that
that's not very useful
now the question can you draw the
complementary stand I always find if
this top strand here which of these is
the complementary strand frankly the
best way to do it is to sketch out the
complementary strand you can see it kind
of upside down because it's really hard
to draw things 5 prime to 3 prime when
you're also trying to figure out base
pairing so draw it upside down make sure
you know the 5 prime and the 3 prime end
and then you can guess the right answer
for these types of questions about
complementary strands now one last
question the stability of
double-stranded DNA I've made a whole
big deal about hydrogen bonding right
that's what holds it together what other
forces could be a play-in double
stranded DNA that might contribute to
its stability
any thoughts what else well it certainly
doesn't look like it's charged because
the predominant charge is negative this
is not not an opportunity probably got
metal ions there kind of neutralizing
that charge what would be the other
force and how would I describe it it's a
tricky one so we've got these bases and
they're pretty hydrophobic they're
planes they have electron density on
both sides so it turns out there is some
stability gained between the packing of
the steps of DNA between each base pair
with the next with the next
so there are hydrophobic forces and
researchers of Scripps have actually
proved this paradigm by making extra DNA
bases that don't have hydrogen bonding
partnerships but just provide the stuff
that's the flat hydrophobic entity with
the right size that can slip into DNA
sequences and make stable addicts
oh it makes stable not really base pairs
anymore but just be stable in that
polymeric structure a people
understanding and following that okay
well so finally when we look at the
structure of DNA there are some trenches
where things can bind to proteins
combined and we talked about the major
groove and the minor groove but I will
talk about those later on when we talk
about transcription factors now I just
want to in really triple past time and
I'll put this on the on the website
there's tremendous interest in using the
building blocks of DNA through
information storage in computing so if
you look up DNA based computing on
Wikipedia you'll learn a whole lot about
it because what's so exciting about is
is it so organized nano scale material
that can be programmed to base param
form certain structures so in the sort
of range of different sizes there's been
a lot of interest in DNA as a material
for information storage not for your
genetic material but for plain old
information storage so people have
learned how to build structures of DNA
where they can construct these sort of
cruciform structures by base pairing
they can make the arms of these
structures a little bit extended so you
could start joining those things
together to make very defined
three-dimensional entities that you in
kind of nuts doing this sort of stuff
because you can build sort of tetrahedra
and other sort of shapes and sizes all
by strands that base pair that are about
10 base pairs long that are stable and
the only complement certain other base
pairs so you could literally build up
they often called it DNA origami because
you can build up macroscopic structures
just by the assembly of strands of DNA
that will ultimately fold to form the
best complementary DNA to form the
structures and it's also been found as I
said they went completely not smiley
faces and stars and stripes
and so on but the most valuable thing
you can as I said you can read more
about this is to use DNA as logic gates
to define and or or not so the sort of
three options and actually use them to
program certain puzzles where the DNA
will spit out the answer to a particular
puzzle through a logic diagram so those
of you who are interested in computing
and these kinds of logic puzzles may
want to read a little bit more because
DNA is such a reliable non-covalent
structure where those base pairs are
incredibly reliable that you can start
envisioning not just building
double-stranded DNA but building all
kinds of architectures or programming
things with the sequence of DNA and
that's it for today and that's the end
of the biochemistry section
you